what was once a factory of death has for
75 years been a factory of remembrance
some of the artifacts of 1.1 million
lives most of them Jews but also poles
Roma Jehovah's Witnesses homosexuals and
prisoners of war these are the places
where they froze and starved where they
were experimented upon huddled together
and killed this is what is left behind
but only a dwindling few know how it
felt
94 year old Leon von Raab was 18 when he
was separated from his family at
Auschwitz you can imagine a son of a
lovely mother I have four other sisters
I was a fair wife child it's a sign how
exhausted I was I do not remember once
to think it what happens was my mother
my sisters I didn't know that they took
my mother and my aunt the same day to
suggestion being killed exactly matter
each year there are fewer and fewer
survivors left to tell their stories the
bricks and mortar will survive them of
course as a visual reminder to the
millions who visit each year but quite
soon that living connection to the
horrors of the Holocaust will be lost
there's a first time it's ever happened
in the history of mankind such thing
what happens here now she's this
industrial killings to kill a whole
nation for three-quarters of a century
those who survived have been around to
tell the world that what happened here
must never be allowed to happen again
when they are gone our wits Birkenau
will be left with one ultimate purpose
that no one should ever be allowed to
forget
Jonah hull al-jazeera a schvitz Birkenau
death camp